you immediately a racist and people
don't want to be called and don't want
to be seen as a racist so this this this
this makes it very difficult for a real
strong popular reaction um um to come
out well I think this is something that
you and I have uh shared that both have
been called this and labeled this many
times yes uh what is your response to
people when you when they say to you
that fitna is racist or Wilders is
racist how's how how do you respond well
I I um I always respond um by saying
that people think that are really not
not only very very wrong but it's it's
it's insulting I mean you can you can
don't you don't have to like my um um
what I'm standing for you can vote on
another party you can say well this will
is a crazy guy whatever you can people
are free to think and do what they like
um but I'm everything but a racist I'm a
I'm a I'm a democratic politicians in
all my Veen I fight uh in within the
rule of law every day again in my
Parliament for my proposals and if I if
they are rejected I accept it and I try
again tomorrow and I have nothing
against I have nothing against anybody
on the basis of of race whatever color
they have whatever sexual preference
they have I don't even have anything
against Muslims Muslims are equal to
anybody I have nothing against them
however I have some I have a problem
with the ideology so you you should make
and I always do that also in My
Parliament you should make a distinction
with between the Islamic ideology which
is very bad indeed you know that better
than I do and the people the majority of
the Muslims in Western Europe are not
criminals or are not terrorists however
say even by saying that we should start
the immigration because even though
those peoples are not criminal if we
have more immigration to Western Europe
our culture will change and
unfortunately not for the better so
racism has really nothing to do with
that if Muslims are integrated or
assimilating in my country and they um
they are equal as anybody else of course
uh yes you you say speaking about
immigration it might be useful to uh ask
you if the Dutch government has any
mechanism whatsoever to try to
distinguish between Muslims who are
bringing the Islamic supremacist
ideology and hoping to impose Sharia
ultimately upon the Netherlands and
Muslims who are interested in
assimilating yes have they are they
evening any attempt to distinguish
between the two no really not the only
attempt they do but it's it's it's a
different cup of tea they ask people to
go to a course in order to not only
learn the language but to get acquainted
with the values of the Netherlands but
then again last year uh we spent they
spent hundreds of millions of Euros in
order to achieve that but the classes
are empty because they are 2/3 is empty
because they are not attending why are
they not attending a because they are
not interested and B because there is no
penalty if they don't come we are not
saying that well you are we spend a lot
of taxpayers money for you to integrate
in our society you're welcome to do that
but if you don't come please leave our
country we are not doing that so there's
no incentive at all to come then again
um I think I would be in favor now all
the problems that we have and all the
demographical problems that we face that
there should be a full stop at least for
a couple of years when it comes to the
immigration from uh Muslim countries
because I believe that and you know the
word taka when I was still at the at the
primary school um but um you know what
what what taka means and it means that
even though there is no mechanism
Muslims can I'm not saying they all do
but they can lie and they can they can
be politically correct but I'm very sure
that if the numbers grow and they will
but not not even become 51% not even a
majority I mean you know there have been
studies where countries being compared
where the Muslim population was 15 20 25
30% and even if they are not a majority
but become stronger they will change
their tune and the islamization will be
very hard and to be returned into what
we have today oh quite so and we're
already seeing that yeah you mentioned a
little while back uh islamization and
the demands for accommodation we're
seeing those increasingly in the United
States yeah uh they've actually stepped
up uh markedly over just the last couple
of years and uh I have been reporting on
them and uh for example people saying in
uh the uh Swift meat packing plants in
Nebraska and Colorado that they the
Muslims saying that they will not uh
take the breaks at the ordinary times
they demand that the break schedule be
changed so that they can stop work and
break the Ramadan fast and the uh meat
packing clant was happy to accommodate
them uh but then the non-muslims
protested and and said that this meant
that they had to work longer hours and
they were being put at a disadvantage
Visa the Muslim employees now my
question is the uh the reaction to uh my
reporting on some of these stories has
been uh people saying that uh this is
just hysteria that uh it's it's it's
hysteria if not something worse it may
be racism or bigotry here again that uh
there are reasonable accommodations
given to all sorts of groups
uh uh Orthodox Jews had won permission
to wear the kipa in various
circumstances uh in various professional
activities why should it be any
different to Grant a few cultural
accommodations to Muslims and
uh they say that if somebody opposes
this for Muslims while favoring it for
Jews or other groups then obviously
there's something there that has to do
with simple islamophobia and nothing
else well it has I believe it has
nothing to do with Islam phobia first um
is um I believe it's very important to
say that we should the biggest disease
in Europe today Robert is U IL lethal
disease is called cultural relativism
this is um the first thing we should we
should fight and go to the doctor for
and find a good prescription by the most
political Elite people tend to say out
of political correctness or maybe
postcolonial guilt or whatever reason
that um the Islamic culture is the same
as the as the Jewish or the Christian
culture and tradition but this is so
wrong this is not true it's not even um
a real class of civilizations I I I I I
I I subscribe to what the brave uh woman
waa sulan said about this he says it's
not even a clash of civilization it's a
clash between rationality and barbarism
or backwardness and um one difference as
well is that the islamization Islam
comes to the West
not to um assimilate not to integrate
that is a mistake that that many people
also in my country make and if you go
out of the idea that people are here to
assimilate why should you not um um um
give them a holiday or let them work
earlier or whatever but this is not the
truth they are there um um to submit us
they are there to um to over rulers they
are there um to to change the whole
country into their system and Islam um
um knows nothing but Islam and um um it
has no place for anything else but Islam
so if we would accommodate it let me
tell you it will be not just one step
the day after we give them public
holiday or compulsory halal food on
schools the next day it will be
something else and the day after it will
be something else again and this is very
bad and I'm I'm very disappointed also
in my own country we have a Cabinet
member and she's from a CHR Christian
party the Christian union party and she
said publicly that she could imagine
that um the end of the Ramadan would be
um a national holiday in the Netherlands
can you remember a Christian member of
the Dutch cabinet and there was an
enormous public outrage I mean I was
happy that she said it even though it
was stupid because it showed that the
people are increasingly fatter by the
accommodation um and the appeasing of
Muslim minority and but more importantly
the culture that wants to destroy us
because this is the end of the day what
Islam will do it will destroy everything
that we stand for and the more we
accommodate them and the less we will
get in return I'm sure of
that